[Music]
[Music]
blake shelton might need a minute to
shake off his attempt at singing taylor
swift's shake it off i love it
in a teaser clip for jimmy fallon's new
nbc game show that's my jam the country
singer teams up with ariana grande to
take on their fellow coaches on the
voice kelly clarkson and john legend
going lyric for lyric in a hilarious
game of slay it don't spray it it's just
very exciting the rules are simple spin
the wheel and sing whatever song it
lands on word for word miss a lyric and
you'll get sprayed
oh no well the wheel landed on taylor's
hit 2014 track and things were off to a
solid start until it was blake's turn to
nail the lyrics
[Music]
so i know what you're thinking maybe it
gets better yeah not so much
[Music]
i got this music
yeah ari was out of there trying to
avoid the inevitable getting hosed down
it was like so crazy
[Applause]
so clearly team aryan blake lost the
battle but flake
he won the war pushing jimmy into the
booth to experience the
um
fun have you ever done this as the host
of the show have you ever been in
[Applause]
just see what it's like uh on come on
come on
come on man
this is your show
this is a great opportunity for you
jimmy
[Applause]
fans can watch the full episode when it
premieres january 3rd on nbc
but before that blake will celebrate a
big milestone his first christmas as a
married man to gwen stefani wow
christmas the two tied the knot back in
july and when e.t chatted with the no
doubt singer earlier this month she
dished on their holiday tradition we do
the timpano dome i don't know if you've
heard of it it's this like layered pasta
italian dish and last year we screwed up
guys i'm sorry it was a mess so i'm
hoping to you know
make something that to make up for last
year and um we were going to make sure
that we did everything from scratch and
it's just we love doing it we love
making the memories christmas is all
about making the memories and so um it's
it's really fun and we're really looking
forward to it we go big we're going to
go big we're going to go big speaking of
going big notes for blake shelton what
does
gwen stefani want for christmas
ooh you know what
i thought about this a lot blake
you did great you did great no i just
honestly
i just want everyone to be happy and
have that moment you know what i'm
saying it feels like there's a lot of
stress in the air and i just want my
kids to have just the most great
memories that we could ever make
together this christmas and i i know
that we'll be able to do that